et bien bonjour les amis aujourd'hui
énorme surprise intentions j'ai le
plaisir de vous présenter partie on
avait dit aux mots surpris et bien
bonjour les amis aujourd'hui énorme
surprise j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir bi
xénon et molly et dans le studio ça va
les gars alors aujourd'hui les amis
programme ils sont mettez-vous en place
et il m'est arrivé un peu ou bien tu
veux un café non mais ok les amis
aujourd'hui je vous invite pour quoi
j'ai essayé il ya plusieurs mois de
faire une musique avec aujourd'hui à
2,23
oui voici ce que ça donne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vraiment vraiment un bon ami aujourd'hui
j'ai voulu refaire cet exercice avec de
la fraîcheur avec des jeunes talents
gilliam bouteilles ou des professions
qui vient de sortir un nouvel album à
sans promo c'est parti vous avez cinq
secondes liasse alors on l'a sorti de
nouvel album il s'appelle la vraie vie
c'est le deuxième super faut soutenir
c'est bon c'est bon maintenant vous êtes
sous mes ordres ok d'accord c'est fini
lance enfin bon on va faire un petit peu
comme stromae faisait à l'époque je ne
compte pas l'épargné qui a travaillé sur
un très bon c'est mon ami c'est mamie qu
on a dit que l'instant pour moi est
déterminé plus tard on va faire une
sorte de lieu sur ok en gros moi des
fois j'ai des mélodies en tête sous
l'eau à bouche aux toilettes ses
mélodies j'aimerais les réaliser j'ai
d'ailleurs acheté chez moi de quoi le
faire mais je n'y arrive pas voici une
photo pour preuve on voit aujourd'hui
réalisés ensemble
première étape un beat voyait en suivant
les mélodies que je vous donnerai
d'accord deuxièmement on va devoir
écrire chacun un couple aussi tu veux
écrire moi aussi oui le mec se mouiller
il se mouiller je me mouille bail
il faut que m mouiller le maillot et
demi au loyer le maillot on va le voir
écrit un couple et chacun plus un
refrain mais il y aura une contrainte
que vous découvrirez en temps réel ok
parce que sinon vous êtes trop chaud
vous allez réussir à faire un truc
[ __ ]
pour le big flo année son petit clavier
la caméra qui est juste ici vous pouvez
voir le clavier de au premier et hop
c'est parti
déjà on va commencer par les accords a
donc par la mélodie
tu vois le truc de base quoi la base
mélodique
voilà la base mélodies ont choisi
d'avoir le son squeeze tu me dis stop
quand c'est le bon ok
pas fou bas folie ordinaire techno j'ai
dit est que noah c'était par la vie
depuis 2009 là j'aime bien la jeune
vierge alors mais sur un truc on est sur
la fraîcheur je peux me permettre de
donner ma mélodie
oui j'aimerais un truc qu'ils fassent ça
ne sent pas je me sens pas déjà tu m'a
coupé c'est perdre excusez mon talent un
tintin tintin tintin tintin tintin
romantique du genre ok ça ne va ok bon
je me le fais au prof vous aurez compris
que je serrerai dans le groupe attaqué
[Musique]
non c'est ça alors comme tous les jours
chez vous à la maison je deviens avicii
getaria pas parce qu'on l'enregistré
qu'on le conte le loupe
[Musique]
la base mélodique elle est bonne on
passe maintenant aux beats je vous cache
pas que j'ai déjà - en fait des trucs
que j'ai déjà fait à la vente en gros là
j'ai le charles et jérémy hussler et là
je le kick énorme caisse claire charley
c'est parti moi je vais faire deux trois
et ya ya ya ya ya ya ya
ok il a frustré tout le monde maintenant
qu'est-ce qui manque nous manque une
basse et voix aux [ __ ] je suis pas
directeur du gestionnaire et à froid la
basse
on va de la basse ça suit toujours
enfin normalement ça celui-là la tunique
ce qu'on appelle la tonique c'est à dire
la la note dominante dans les accords
dosol famille mes mains ce qui est drôle
c'est qu'à chaque fois je devais vous
donner le la mélodie mais je suis
tellement fumée que à part le premier
truc
après je sais pas vous mais moi c'est ça
j'ai trouvé la base est ce qu'on peut
dire pas ça
dans
[Musique]
hall enregis c'est un tube à l'ego je
voudrais je voudrais une photo de la
boule de fort boyard j'ai droit sur le
monde revient sur ses parties de boules
de foyers alors merci
il est décédé oui tu sais pas tu sais
oui oui on va surtout parler d'eux ouais
ouais ouais ouais attend c'est pas fini
le truc c'est trop simple de faire une
prod comme ça machin fait d'une relevé
essayez d'intégrer un bout d'une de tes
vidéos dans le bus j'ai perdu ça ça va
je le prends tu le prince merci à tous
au goudron gone wrong la blague
volià le cri la traîne là se teinte en
crise crise
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est génial je vois je trouve ça
encore trop simple j'ai pris ton cri
parce que c'était trop simple de le
coller juste comme ça et j'en ai fait un
instrument
[Applaudissements]
maintenant tu vas payer des royalties
bon après ça j'étais une petite mélodie
ça donne ça les amis après tout c'est
qu'il n'est pas temps d'écouter le
morceau final avec absolument toutes les
pistes active et j'appuie avec le
dictionnaire sur la barre espace
pourquoi un dictionnaire vous allez voir
ya ya ya ya ya
attention c'est un mois dédié à la
prochaine étape
écrire les paroles les amis voici c'est
quoi la contrainte alors alors voici le
petit robert tu connais toi même tu
connais pourquoi au déjà c'est parce
qu'arrivé au hasard dans le dictionnaire
jeu non je suis plus original que ça
comme on dit stop
jouve le dictionnaire et je choisis un
mot qui assure la page avoir choisi le
mot de la poche bien sûr alors ce parce
vous savez mais ce dictionnaire était
dirigée par alain reille un gros gros
bien je ne sais pas et ça veut dire quoi
diriger un dictionnaire
ah oui les mots aux actes on attend à
l'impasse qu'on peut pas on peut pas
écrire indique aussi l'arrivée les gars
est-ce que je peux mon affaire les dés
aujourd'hui on commence par big flo mais
il faut me suis dit stop punition ça va
les contacter soit g soit grammaire
allègrement g stop pétrissage là ça
commence à lyon de détruire stock
riziculture définition quand même pour
les non initiés
alors la rupture sur c'est la culture du
riz c'est bon pour toi de courry
capituler pas la culture du rire la
punition grammaire pétrissage
riziculture je te laisse écrire c'est à
toi aussi tu veux mais n'a pour la place
d'hugo est ce que tu es prêt store déjà
fini mon texte
quoi c'est faux avec ça ok inquisitoire
bim je commence direct ok ok c'est toi
top hockey ouf
oh non alors là mon pote tombé sur la
fin des baies donc c'est que les mots
schluck personne n'utilise ya la
bisontine au logis steve qui préfère mon
frère s'abattant c'est l'étude de
l'histoire et la civilisation byzantine
top mono sperme cecos a c'est qu'il ne
contient qu'une seule graine c'est un
fruit monosphere du coup on peut pas
ajouter un mois un plan dur parce que
j'ai envie de te remettre des mots durs
l'attaqué des trucs ça embête 110 est
saisi 10 estiment avec ses troubles de
la sensibilité qui exaspérait ou
affaibli je te prends encore de bon ok
encore de maux alors déguster déguster
savoir thé ça va on est pas mal et
mondialisation monde c'est sûr
les vieux textes de rap conscient des
mondialisations arrive c'est bon tout le
monde a ses petits mots non pas toi les
motifs oui c'est vrai mais bon c'est mon
tour vas-y rendu chez jean bûcher bien
faire entrer la bête dans les bois en le
poursuivant je savais pas du tout
c'était un stop pécuniaire qui fit qui
rapporte l agence à savoir qui
franchement pédagogie ses mots s'il
tient pour aller au pif on s'en bat les
couilles de ouakam et c'est quoi vos
cannes et algues marines brune utilisée
dans la cuisine asiatique qui aime bien
le japon regardez ouakam et je prends
mon cas mais sans bulik relatif au
somnambulisme
ok la gare de lyon se retrouve dans
quelques minutes quand les couplets
seront prêts pierse y est allé à tout à
l'heure
c'est parti joe hockey hier japon comme
une mitraillette jamais à court de
munitions quand j'étais petit j'étais
malin j'habitais tout et punitions
bientôt j'aime barré dans un petit bled
paisible avec celui-ci je suis atteint
de 10 est saisi et les petits savent que
temps je rappe pour ton cerveau mais rim
défend les faits d' un pétrissage
mettreen fleurs sur sa sépulture
la culture est risible va faire de la
riziculture tous les maux sont graves et
culture ici pas faire de la riziculture
béjaïa biffle olic squeezing ok ça fait
y'a big flo et oli cartonne tu as bien
fait d'y croire même si panique comme un
accusé de l'inquisiteur un visionnaire
mais devant dictionnaire je m'applique
la mondialisation c'est déguster des
sushis en afrique myboto cher et les
poteaux buts r d plus petit j'ai un
pétage fois que tu mon père
triste d'anthologie leur faut sont
tellement vieux l'impression de faire la
bise en sinologie oui oui c'est un oui à
moi dire bien sûr merci à tous et placer
tous les mois le micro et là c'est faux
et ça paie yao squeeze je fais un big up
à maurice est ok même bien les mecs
junte youtube via mes jetons rap et
faire du clic j'en aime un trip ceux
d'autres artistes flow somnambulique je
croise des rapports en soirée je leur
dis embûches et je suis déjà c'est
batelli toi je vous ai rarement vu chez
j'aurais pas dû vous clash et non je
sais pas vous calmer les déguste son
cachet je paye mathon des lois gars mais
attention chers parents à but
pédagogique
sinon votre enfant pourrait finir comme
ça pour le squeeze
[Applaudissements]
mardi ils étaient bons ballons
twizy best m6
big four police ramène tout le bordel
sur tu achètes tu vois pas faire pas et
on a les bras sans dire il est mort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
[Musique]